did you ever pull a prank on brad the
act of not pulling a prank that was the
problem it's the fact that he did not
pull a prank he's notorious for that
he'll write pranks out for years and uh
there was much pranking going on
and uh
i made the mistake of lending out my
room key and uh then it hit me whoa what
did i do what did i do
and for then for the next two months
proceeding i i come home and spend about
45 minutes searching my room that was
brutal well once i heard that he was
checking his room every night then i
just stayed home i did a lot of reading
you know we could find a picture of you
in there too i have a quick
impersonation
exactly the whole idea of doing this
movie from day one minute one did you
say that's a bad idea bad bad bad that
was a bad idea like to apologize now for
it but we've changed the title oh dear
is that right yeah it's harry potter too
good yeah good plan oh he's using the
noodle right here yeah yeah a little
wizardry idea man
you're out right now and whose idea was
it to have him eat the whole time like
he never eats his idea his idea yeah no
uh yeah
yeah just kind of started didn't stop
you know he eats it out he eats he does
nothing happens
he doesn't he's got a system on him yeah
that's annoying oh yeah i know that's
just another reason to hate him there's
plenty of reason to hate him let me tell
you turn that camera off and i'll tell
you some stories i just like at the end
when you just finally have had enough
i use my breasts to get other people's
attention
we both do that
[Applause]
you made a guest appearance on friends
yes i did you yes i did did you
yeah
first year played a doctor you're cool i
play doctor pretty much all the time
i'll take a look at him oh thank you
michael rachel what monica oh hi
mike it was it was such fun it was such
fun yeah i
i love that show it makes me happy it's
always made me happy i don't know what
it is about that show this is long
before i met my wife are you gonna be
okay well i'll i'll be fine just
god i hate it ross i feed her and they
graciously uh accepted me on the show
and it was great fun man great fun play
long enough you never change the stakes
the house takes you unless when that
perfect hand comes along you bet big and
then you take the house i've been
practicing this speech a little bit did
i rush it felt like i was good i liked
it have you ever stolen anything ever
why are bad questions going around
tonight oh cause i think oh cause
uh all right stole anything ever yeah i
just once i stole uh
a
67 chevy
i steal hearts
[Music]